so let's talk a little bit about money
personalities and take it all with a
grain of salt anytime I see any of these
personality tests uh that try to
classify you in one way or another I'm
like I'm a complex human being I have
many different facets to my personality
but they do uh end up being helpful for
just making us reflect on how we're
behaving or how we tend to behave at
certain times so the general money
personalities are the Savor the spender
the investor and then someone who's
pretty balanced on all of the above and
maybe there's a fifth category of the
avoider now the saver and I think I fall
under this it tends to be a little bit
Frugal they're good at uh saving money
so they bring in more money than they
necessarily spend and that's generally a
good thing but it can have some
downsides sometimes the saver doesn't
put as much money as uh they need to
enjoy life after all what is the money
for at the end of the day now related to
this saver we could think about the
investor which I kind of view as a saver
who is willing to put their money to
work a little bit more now when you put
your money to work it's often involves a
little bit more risk so if you're a pure
saver maybe you just like to a little
bit hoard that money but you keep it
really really secure while an investor
maybe takes a little bit more risk which
could be a good thing because a little
bit more risk a little bit more return
potentially but it's also more risk
which means you might lose some so if
you're an investor as long as you're
investing prudently it could be a very
good thing but you have to be aware of
how much risk you're actually taking on
you might be taking on too much risk now
the third category is the spender you
could imagine what that is I think we've
all been in that mode a little bit but I
think you're a classic spender if you're
kind of living in the moment when you
spend you're not really thinking about
how much money you have or what your
goals are and Spenders can get into a
good bit of trouble out of all of the
categories probably the most trouble
where they can overspend not be able to
keep up with their bills and obviously
if you're only thinking about the moment
you might be doing some harm to your
future self and then you have the
balancer now the bouncer overall sounds
like a pretty good category uh it means
that you're you're balanced across all
of them but even there you might want to
make sure that uh you know you're not
prone to maybe indecision oh do I save
do I spend what do I do but overall it
sounds like a pretty good thing now
avoider is someone who just doesn't like
to think about money at all now probably
Spenders and avoiders might have some
common characteristics if you're really
if you're a real spender you might not
want to think about financial literacy
you might want to avoid thinking about
money altogether and that's what an
avoider is doing to some degrees just
say well let me just not think about it
money kind of stresses me out and
obviously avoiders similar to Spenders
when you're just living that moment you
can get yourself into a little bit of
trouble so think about what Financial
personality you are maybe you're
evolving in your financial personalities
maybe at different moments of your life
in certain dimensions of your life
you're more of one or the other I tend
to be a spender when it comes to fruit I
tend to be a saver when it comes to
clothing but just think about it it'll
give you a nice framework for uh how you
tend to be